all right it's time for you to start
applying the layout skills you just
learned and here's what it looks like on
desktop not that great I think you can
do a lot better for this part in the
project pick a set of breakpoints that
you think look good and then use one of
the patterns that you just learned to
style the page so it looks great even on
desktop and tablet if you didn't finish
the exercise from the last time you
worked on the project don't worry you
can grab a working copy linked in the
instructor notes below make sure that
you test on phones tablets and browser
windows of all different sizes so that
you get a sense of what the page looks
like everywhere adjust your breakpoints
until you get something that you're
happy with and remember what might work
on one phone might not work so well on
others and of course if you can make
sure that you test on real devices as
well because sometimes you'll uncover
unexpected behavior or design elements
that well you just didn't expect I'm
going to show you what we came up with
but this is by no means the right answer
this is just what we like and you could
totally go in a different direction and
if you're happy with it
then that's great but this is what we
did I've got a breakpoint here and then
another breakpoint there the important
part of this part of the project is that
you try out different layout patterns
and find out what you like good luck